a ukrainian woman with three children
fleeing the war in her homeland was
denied entry to the u.s twice when she
asked for asylum at the tijuana border
crossing with mexico i don't have any
other place to go sophia who did not
give her last name traveled first to
romania then to mexico seeking to enter
the u.s
actually i have family and friends in
usa and they're ready to support me
and actually they asked me to leave
ukraine in this situation
since 2020 the u.s has barred almost all
asylum seekers using a regulation meant
to prevent infectious diseases from
spreading across the border now with
many covet-era restrictions eased or
eliminated the rule known as title 42 is
still being used to bar thousands of
people from mexico central america
africa haiti and elsewhere many of those
migrants are fleeing war and political
upheaval but on her third try sophia and
her children with help from a lawyer
were allowed to enter the u.s
some immigration attorneys say there is
a double standard favoring ukrainians we
are absolutely seeing a differentiation
between how we're treating ukrainian
asylum seekers than we are other asylum
seekers whether they be from south
america cameroon
haiti or afghanistan the ukrainians are
being able to jump to the front of the
line and the only difference is that
they're white and all of these other
asylum seekers are not white we're going
to welcome ukrainian refugees with open
arms if in fact they come all the way
here
the biden administration quickly granted
temporary residency to tens of thousands
of ukrainians who are already in the u.s
we will be providing temporary protected
status
tps to those ukrainian nationals who are
present in the united states as of march
1st of this year that policy also favors
ukrainians over citizens of other
nations who have been asking for
temporary protected status the afghans
have been begging for this since august
2021
last month 427 ukrainians entered the
u.s as refugees more than triple the
number from january there will be more
families from ukraine seeking refuge in
the u.s as russia's invasion grinds on
and raising more troubling questions
about fairness
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles